been on Mark Wahlberg's social media
recently no he doesn't add a lot of
context he just will start the video and
he's like already mid thought cold
plunge challenge this is watch out Jojo
this thing is as cold as I've ever felt
the entire life is like going into the
Atlantic come here babe
the Pacific
why do okay that's it that's it okay
what is what the [__] is the point of
that I feel when I watch these as though
I'm watching like a 19 year old junkie
or something yo Mario cold plunge the
coolest plunge I have a plunged
sick cobra
like the like the an attic
is that what he said I don't know he
slides in there or the Pacific shut up
[__]
[Laughter]